well chase we got some bad news for you
about that whole playing on thanksgiving
thing if you haven't heard raven
steelers has been moved to sunday
because the ongoing outbreak with the
baltimore ravens we'll be talking about
that plenty over the course of the next
hour shireen williams mike florio with
you here on pft pm live on peacock and
wednesday's the day that we're also live
on sky sports so hello to our friends in
the uk and in ireland we understand
you're still on lockdown we are with you
in spirit if not in body but once the
world gets back to normal i know i'm
going to england shireen can we persuade
you to join us when we go to england for
the pft live tour of our friends in in
that great continent
i'm honored the last time i went was
when the cowboys played the the jaguars
there yes i love love it have been
multiple times i've never been to
ireland but but love the uk
and would love to go back
well that's only one of the many reasons
it will be great when the world is back
to normal but the clearest indication as
far as the nfl is concerned the world is
not back to normal the latest
postponement and it had been several
weeks since a game had been moved and
this one is this most significant game
moved yet because it is the thanksgiving
night game for the first time since 2005
there will be no nfl football at night i
don't know what i'm going to do tomorrow
night but i know what i'm going to be
doing on sunday shireen because the game
has been moved to 1 15 p.m eastern nbc
broadcast
nationally televised i can't remember
the specific year but my guess is this
will be the first time there's a regular
season sunday afternoon game on nbc
since 1997
ish or thereabouts so it's historic in
that regard and uh just a you know a
crazy situation that i've had to deal
with and i i i was surprised
initially
because the nfl has been in this mode
serena we've talked about it all week
get the games in get the games in get
the games in but
if one of the teams is still in the
midst of an outbreak that they haven't
contained yet and they're not sure how
deep that rabbit hole goes you can't put
that team on a plane you can't put that
team in a locker room you can't put that
team on a sideline and you ultimately
can't put that team on a football field
against the pittsburgh steelers so for
as upset as the steelers players were
they should be grateful they didn't get
subjected to
a team of ravens players any or all of
whom could be shedding virus on them
tomorrow night
mike first of all i think it's the right
decision that the nfl made obviously
it's late and i realize the steelers are
upset about it because they were going
to have a four day weekend and guess
what now they don't
but
also i'll say this i'm surprised and i'm
surprised for two reasons one if you
remember back to that 49ers packers
games
the 49ers were not only injury decimated
but they had so many coveted cases then
that they were told we were still
playing the game they played the game
they were awful and i wonder if that
went into the nfl's thinking too that
the 49ers had no chance in that game it
was a horrible game to watch the packers
down and they might have dominated them
anyway no question about it but they
really didn't give them a chance because
of the coveted cases and it was a
horrible game but the second reason i'm
surprised that it was moved just as you
said it's thanksgiving night it's huge
ratings it's everyone wants to see that
game and now we don't have that game and
i know there's a lot of disappointment
that we don't have that game and their
options frankly were limited moving this
game we know they can't play it saturday
because of college football
friday would have been to me a great
decision to move to friday night but you
don't know if they're going to be
cleared yeah they can't can't do it
you already have a game sunday night
there's nothing and they play again the
ravens play again next thursday against
the cowboys so the options were limited
you either play it thursday night or you
play it sunday as they're doing
cannot play friday nights until the
middle of december as part of the same
law that prevents the nfl from
televising saturday games between labor
day weekend and the first weekend in
december fridays and saturdays are off
limits to protect high school and
college football that's part of the
broadcast anti-trust exemption and i
doubt that they could have gotten some
sort of dispensation from congress in 48
hours
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports